so I just moved to Nashville and I went
to a thrift store to buy some cheap
furniture I was so excited while
checking out the guy didn't even ask but
I was like I just moved here so he asks
Oh Yeah from where and I say from LA and
he goes oh Laura Alabama I hear it's
real nice down there and I say no
California and he looks at me and says
well welcome to America
and I said thank you sir
that's the thing sometimes people say
don't California my Tennessee or hey
don't you know don't you bring your
stupid politics over here but the thing
is basically anybody who leaves LA to
come to Tennessee Texas Florida
you're pretty right wing you're are
you're signed up welcome to America
thank you sir